hey 42 here having an itch can be a
pretty nasty thing severe itches can be
caused by bug bites sunburn and poison
ivy millions of people around the world
suffer from a skin condition called
dermatitis where an individual skin
becomes very dry and itching when they
come into contact with certain things
such as laundry detergent and jewelry
some people who have atopic dermatitis a
type of eczema actually scratched during
their sleep in many cases sufferers of
chronic itches will uncontrollably
scratch themselves until they bleed
according to Martin smells a
neurophysiologist at the University of
Mannheim in Germany quality of life is
decreased by itch to the same degree as
it is by pain but people don't have
nearly as much empathy for those with a
chronic itch as those who have pain
about 9% of people have some sort of
chronic itch problem so finding a cure
for reaching will be a medical
revolution there is actually a
conference dedicated to this subject
called the international workshop for
the study of itch which hundreds of
scientists and researchers attend
because even though there have been
small advances in the field
pitching is still a bit of a mystery and
we're still a long way from a cure but a
niche isn't just a form of mild pain
pain causes us to recoil whereas an itch
just gives us an unpleasant desire to
scratch itching has its own matrix of
nerves and chemicals completely separate
from those used to relay pain but why do
we itch luckily for us eating can only
occur in the top two layers of our skin
we can't get internal itches thank God
animals develop itches when they have
bugs and parasites on their skin itching
is a natural defense mechanism against
these insects which can give the animals
infections animal scraps to remove the
bugs because their body has signaled to
them via an itch that something very
small is attacking them one widely
adopted theory is that we it because we
still have a primate instinct to do so a
defense mechanism such as this is an
evolutionary advantage so it makes sense
for our bodies to keep it
after all we aren't safe from parasites
either so ultimately we itch to defend
ourselves from parasites and infection
or anything which could irritate our
skin such as stinging nettles when we
get in it
dedicated cells around the affected area
release an organic nitrogen compound
called histamine these histamine send
signals through our brain
more specifically the cerebral cortex
which controls our conscious thoughts
our cerebral cortex then tells us we
have an itch antihistamines work by
stopping the histamines from reaching
their receptors but why does scratching
relieve an itch scratching the skin
blocks activity of the cells in the
spinothalamic tract a sensory pathway
originating in the spinal cord
this lack of activity prevents the
spinal cord from sending signals to our
brain that we have an itch therefore the
itch stops people who have a limb
amputated experience a syndrome called
phantom limb where the amputee feels
severe itching where the limb used to be
this phenomenon occurs in over 90% of
amputees itching is contagious when we
see someone else scratching themselves
we develop pictures from nowhere in
recent studies by researchers at the
University of Hull and Sussex in the UK
participant was showing videos of people
scratching their bodies 64% of the test
subjects scratch themselves whilst
watching the videos you can even
manifest itches by just thinking about
itches in fact you're probably feeling
gets you whilst watching this video but
why in MRI scans researchers found that
when people see other scrubs the parts
of their brain associated with having an
itch were activated it's not empathy
that causes this we don't feel sorry for
the person with an itch
it's neuroticism neuroticism is a
tendency to feel negative emotions in
the studies the people who are the most
neurotic suffered the most from
contagious itching thanks for watching
until next time